recently a contest was launched for
those interested in making physics and
or Consciousness explainer videos it's
essentially the physics Consciousness
version of three blue one Browns contest
and Brilliant has come on board to divvy
5000 USD equally among the top five the
details are linked below if you'd like
to submit your understanding or
explanation of some ctmu concept or how
bernardo's analytical idealism works
then feel free Chris Langan is an
autodidact who has the highest reported
IQ in America and he's conceived of an
extremely inventive Theory of Everything
based in language or meta language and
logic or metallogic called the cognitive
theoretic model of the universe or the
ctmu for short the link to Chris's ctmu
YouTube channel as well as other links
are in the description Bernardo Castro
is the executive director of the
Essentia Foundation bernardo's one of
the most cogent champions of
metaphysical idealism that is the notion
that reality is essentially mental and
he puts this forward with analytical
Precision the link to bring bernardo's
YouTube page and other links are in the
description as well in this podcast
Bernardo and Christ both expound on
their views on Consciousness on
computation and whether materialism or
idealism is most coherent my name is
Kurt J mungle I'm a torontonian
filmmaker with the background in
mathematical physics dedicated to the
explication of the variegated terrains
of theories of everything that is
primarily from a physics perspective but
as well as exploring the possible
connection Consciousness has to the
fundamental laws of nature provided
these laws exist at all and are knowable
to us if you'd like to hear more
podcasts like these then do consider
going to patreon.com
and supporting with whatever you can as
support from the patrons and the
sponsors are the only reason I'm able to
do this full time so thank you and now
thanks to the sponsors the first of
which is brilliant Brilliance is a place
to learn math science and engineering
through bite-sized Interactive Learning
experiences if you're interested in
theories of everything from a physics
perspective then you've likely heard of
Constructor Theory which is a toe that's
heavily predicated in information Theory
so I decided to take Brilliance course
on random variable distributions and
knowledge uncertainty and after taking
that course I can finally see why the
formula for entropy is defined the way
that it is it's actually an extremely
natural formula you can also learn group
theory if you're interested in the
standard model then you'll need to know
what U1 processed U2 cross s23 is visit
brilliant.org toe to get 20 off the
annual subscription I recommend that you
don't stop before four lessons keep
pushing until you've done at least four
and I think you'll be greatly surprised
at the ease at which you can now
comprehend subjects you previously had a
difficult time grocking the second
sponsor is nordvpn and the third is
manscaped you'll be hearing much more
about them later they're both joining us
for the first time on tow so I'm
extremely grateful to them thank you and
enjoy this Theo location with Bernardo
Castro and Chris Langan nice to meet you
Chris nice to meet you too Bernardo
plenty of people are excited for this by
the way this I think has the most
upvotes slash comments of any pairing of
any field location so if you have a
fraction of the amount of excitement as
I have I'll I'm super happy about that
people are probably when they watch this
live people are like oh my gosh this I
can't believe this is happening Chris
Langan and Bernardo Castro
okay
well
why don't we start just so you know
we'll talk about metaphysics
Consciousness and computation those are
the general themes for today we'll start
with the substrate independence of
Consciousness quote unquote so
Lambda I'm sure you've heard of this
computer or this algorithm or this AI
called Lambda some people claim it's
indeed conscious
why or why not and we'll start with you
Bernardo if you don't mind
uh certainly not
um when we when we say something is
conscious uh what we normally mean is
that that something has private
conscious in their life that is separate
from yours from mine and from the rest
of nature so to be conscious is to have
private experience private phenomenality
another way to put it and I think we
have absolutely no reason to think that
a silicon mechanism has private inner
life of its own it is it in
Consciousness absolutely everything is
in Consciousness everything begins
unfolds and ends in in a field of
subjectivity that underlies all nature
in my view so Lambda is in Consciousness
that doesn't mean that it is conscious
in and of itself I think what nature is
telling us empirically all the time is
that private conscious in their life
correlates with well life metabolism
protein folding DNA transcription and
ATP burning all that good stuff this is
a far from trivial process metabolism it
uniquely separates biology from
everything else in the universe and it
ties all biology together despite the
tremendous differences between say a an
amoeba run a swimming in my toilet and
me we are completely different yet if
you look down a microscope to the
details of metabolism we are identical
we all do protein folding ATP burning
transcription and all that stuff so
nature is screaming to us that what
private conscious inner life looks like
is warm moist biology metabolism
and Lambda is a silicon computer now can
it emulate or simulate a human cognitive
processing very well well I have little
doubt that it does but the simulation of
a phenomenon is not the phenomenon I
mean I can simulate kidney function on
my computer accurately down to the
molecular level and yet my computer will
not pee on my desk because a simulation
of kidney function is not kidney
function so Lambda is simulating human
intelligence that doesn't mean that it
is conscious because a simulation is not
the thing simulated it's a primary
logical mistake that unfortunately has
been rendered seemingly plausible by our
mad culture because it's being bombarded
on you all the time via the media and
Hollywood movies and Netflix series that
it is plausible for silicon machines to
have private conscious in their life of
of their own even though we have
absolutely zero rational and empirical
reason to think that that's the case
what's your opinion on the same question
if you want I can reread the question
um uh read the question again
I agree with everything the product said
but go ahead and read it again for me
please so whether we basically want to
know whether or not Lambda is indeed
conscious why or why not are you talking
about the Lambda calculus of the program
recently in the news there is this AI
from Google which was much like a
like a talk like a bot a talk bot yeah
I'll probably explain it incorrectly so
Bernardo do you mind explaining what
them does that's it's a chat bot that's
that's what it is yeah and it probably
will pass the Turing test well for what
that means I mean as Bernardo pointed
out that your test isn't the end-all
be-all you've still got a machine
simulator even if it stimulates very
very well and convinces you that it's
human nevertheless it is not human so
basically you're asking well the Lambda
calculus is a construct it's a it's a
computer program it's a mathematical
construct which exists in something that
could be likened to the syntax the
accepting syntax of something in
computation Theory that's called
acceptor you've got acceptors and
processors they transduce information
they accept input and output from the
external world then they process it
internally so we're talking about
Consciousness being the internal phase
of that process
and the idea is the
metaphysics as far as metaphysics is
concerned
as far as I'm concerned anyway in my
opinion
metaphysics is about putting the metal
side of your existence in contact with
the physical side we understand the
physical side quite well thanks to the
empirical sciences and the metal side uh
we don't have such a firm grasp
um Kant you know came up and started
talking about mental categories in terms
of which we perceive phenomenal reality
and uh that gives us a clue as to what
we're talking about here we are talking
about something very much like accepting
syntax with a computational acceptable
okay the idea of putting those two
things together requires something
called all we have to do is we
it's a very simple operation we we
basically say that cognition is akin to
a cognitive identity language it allows
us to identify things so it's a language
then we say the physical universe is a
manifold
space-time manifold out there in which
things are happening the idea then is to
connect these two things that takes a
kind of metal language that spans both
the both of these two object languages
that we have one of which deals with
values coordinate systems and things
like that that's the the manifold and
then you've got the other side which is
qualitative more qualitative more
attribute right that's the mental side
so we're uniting those two things in one
metaphormal language that has to be
quantized in a certain way
and those identity operators that I was
just talking about that are a little bit
like computational acceptors those are
the quantum
okay they're active science
if you look at the linguistic aspect of
what I'm talking about there active
science in the language but they are
also the points of the manifold or the
universe that contains the content to
which you refer with the language
call me
this is a mathematical this is a this is
something that you know I did 30 years
ago and I more or less had my own way of
talking about it let me know if I'm uh
losing it sure so I have a quick
question and then Bernardo please jump
in if you're unsure or you have
clarifying questions so you said that
there's a mental world and then there's
something like the physical world which
you said is like a manifold well they're
both seeing a metaphormally coupled you
can't if you take a state
it consists of attributes and values for
the attributes you can't take those two
things apart
what I'm saying is they're metaphormally
coupled all right you can you can deal
with pure attributes but but you can't
do that without instances or at any rate
a cognitive identity operator to
actually perform the metal functions
involved right
so there's no way and as far as the
values are concerned you take a an
object without attributes that's an
oxymoron okay there is no object that is
totally without attributes you've pinned
an attribute on it by calling it an
object
okay so you can't take those two things
apart there's simply no way to do it so
this dualism between the metal and
physical sides of reality and I say is
nonsense it takes this metaformal
approach in this metaphorical metal
elements that I'm talking
Bernardo do you have any thoughts on
that
or questions increase jumped into
probably more details of his theory
which I'm not acquainted with so if I
start asking questions now you'll
probably
speak for the next two hours just for me
to understand something I should have
understood by reading a paper which I
haven't read so I'm not going to tax you
with this uh Chris yeah well what I was
trying to to answer more or less was the
idea of what metaphysics is and how
Consciousness relates to metaphysics
okay so what I'm saying is that
metaphysics has to be this metaphormal
metal language and Consciousness relates
to it as a distributed property thereof
that that would be your your particular
usage of the word metaphysics or in
metaphysics is a word that has been used
since you know the pre-socratic so there
is there is a sort of a
common common meaning for the word in
philosophy metaphysics that which stands
behind physics or the essence or the
beingness of things as opposed to
appearances and behavior precisely I'm
saying that has to take the form of a
metaphormal metal language
of some metal and physical sides of
reality in other words span between both
of those things building a bridge
between them that's the purpose of
metaphysics and I understand that many
different people have have defined it in
many different ways and the long and
short of it is although I'm you know
respect you know people having their own
ideas about things I don't find that
especially useful you can go and look at
everybody's definition and not come out
with anything very stable that you can
work with so I settled on a mathematical
structure that I can work with to make
sense of these Concepts these
metaphysical Concepts
okay so how about we talk about
computation so what does computation
mean what is reality's relationship to
computation obviously that depends on
one's definition of reality let me tell
you the reason why I'm asking this
question it's because some people think
that our
conscious experiences generated by an
algorithmic process and then some people
don't think that so for example Penrose
famously and secondly some people think
reality is understood as
or is equivalent to computation so
Wolfram for example again the question
is
what is computation and what is its
relationship to reality Bernardo
in its most generic definition
computation just means changes of state
When Future State states depend on
previous States then you have a
computation it's the function by means
of which you create future States based
on past States that's the most generic
possible definition of computation some
of the other things you brought up
attach more you know qualifications to
the word computation uh Wolfram
um considers the laws of physics to be
emergent from cellular automata like
computation in other words local
computations based on Simple Rules so
now you're not saying only computation
now you're specifying more what kind of
computation is involved then you have
digital physics in which the idea is
that the laws of physics should be
reducible to digital computations
so you're specifying what kind of
computation there are analog analog
there has been analog computers in our
history and less than 100 years ago so
computer education is not only digital
so most people when they say well nature
is a computer usually they mean
something more than to just say
computations happen because yes
computations happen the state of the
universe is changing so it's Computing
by definition there is nothing
metaphysically polemic or or or
complicated about it it is when you add
more qualifications to what you mean
that's where it gets tricky when you say
for instance that Consciousness does not
have a non-tick reality of its own but
is the result of a computation and
therefore Epi phenomenon in some sense
now you're seeing more than just that
the Universe computes now you're saying
not only does the universe compute
sometimes its structures its
computations in such a way that it
produces an app phenomenal results that
we know as Consciousness now you're
saying something distinct and absolutely
wrong and internally contradictory and
incoherent and explanatory powerless but
at least you were saying something Ben
Rosa would say that um uh in an
orchestrated reduction together with the
hammeroff they would say that it's one
Mass crosses a certain threshold that
you have collapsed and the moment of
collapse is an experience so they're
saying a lot more than to just say the
Universe computes
um so if you stick to the general thing
the Universe computes I would say of
course because computational computation
generically speaking just means that
there are State transitions and future
states are based on prior states which
we know empirically is what's happening
in the universe the universe doesn't
begin at every moment independently of
what the state was before or as it would
be completely random and it's not it's
predictable so yes there are
computations
um but that's a very generic and
non-polemical thing to say
Chris again so the question is
what is computation and what's reality's
relationship to computation and again
what's behind the question is some
people think that the mind has to be
non-algorithmic like Penrose and also
some people right and then some people
think that reality itself is algorithmic
or computational like Wolfram
okay uh the problem with uh you know
computations with a turing machine does
a turing machine can do its computations
in one of two ways to go to you know
recursive process and it can either do
things deterministically like Bernardo
was talking about something in the past
happens then you've got causal efficacy
within the machine and then something
else happens or it can do it
non-deterministically which means that
it's making random choices in either
case those don't describe Consciousness
because those random
junctures those they're disconnects
Consciousness is something that is a we
understand it as a pretty much
continuous process all right whereas
there's a if you if you take
non-deterministic combination or
computation there is this disconnect
there right whereas if it's
deterministic then cognitive then then
Consciousness is completely
truth okay in other words a
deterministic process gives you no room
for free will doesn't allow you to make
choices doesn't allow you to realize
your uh your will as shovana put it you
see what I mean so these are that's
that's the main limitation of
computation Theory the fact that you've
got this pseudo-causal dichotomy between
determinacy and randomness
now there's a third way to look at
things and that is called
self-deterpacing right and that is what
occurs in the metaformal system which is
why instead of using computation to
model this whole thing I use something
called proto-computation
is you know Quantum turing machine is a
little bit like a like a classical
turing machine still got the tape it's
still got the uh the processor you know
it's that tape by the way that's like a
typographical array and formal systems
and this is once again inadequate the
reality is is generative it actually has
a way of putting itself together from
scratch originate it originates things
rather than causing them
so that would be my answer to the
shortfalls of computation and modeling
consciousness if I if I can just comment
on something
um
I didn't
when I said the universe certainly
computes I didn't mean to restrict it to
deterministic computation I know that
there is indeterministic or
non-deterministic computation quantum
computers are not deterministic and yet
they produce uh precise solutions to
very complicated problems solutions that
you can test and see while they are
really solutions they do so
mechanistically right
it
well there has to be structure to
computation we may call that mechanistic
if we want
um but there has to be structure
otherwise it's just Randomness
um the universe doesn't seem to be
completely random there is order and
there are regularities in nature we
model them in the form that we call the
laws of physics so there is at least
emergent order even if it's not there
from the beginning which I think is a
tough case to make but I'm I'm sensitive
to the possibility there is at least
emergent order
and even with a fundamentally
non-deterministic substrate at the
bottom level you can still perform
meaningful computations by playing with
this the emergent statistical rules like
quantum physics is indeterministic on a
case-by-case basis but because of the
law of large numbers the statistics are
very nicely predictable and that's what
Quantum compute series will leverage
they will leverage that emerging order
that comes with the law of large and
large numbers and produce very precise
and accurate solutions to problems so
computations can be meaningful
and computations and
non-deterministic
probability Theory you can't get the
randomness out of it you take all the
randomness out of probability Theory and
it ceases to be a probability Theory
then it becomes a classical mechanistic
system right in order to accommodate
that we change some classical mechanics
to Quantum Mechanics we need something
more than that something that is
pre-real with John Wheeler called
pre-geometry we need something that
actually precedes mechanisms that
precedes computational that even
precedes cognition and that is what I
refer to as with Chopin I referred to as
well what I refer to as Telesis
this is we would have this underlying
kind of Prima cax
right which is teleodynamics which is
what this metaphorical language Works in
terms
schopenhauer he
could make a case that he
he was against determinism or you could
make a case that he was a complete
determinist I'm with the Atlanta Camp I
think schopenhauer was a total
determinist he believed in determinism
he his famous statement that yeah you
can act according to your will but you
cannot will what you will in other words
what you will is already determined so
that you can follow your choices doesn't
mean that there is no determinism
because you're you're willing uh is
already determined right what I was
referring is the you know the title of
this Magnum office the word this will
and representation basically the will
has to somehow proceed the
representation or is totally useless and
trivial okay I don't think that that
Chopin hour was saying something trivia
I think that he actually felt that the
will had something to do you know with
reality Above and Beyond Simple
representation
of the world for schopenhauer that's
correct no but how couldn't be
deterministic how can it be
deterministic without idea or
representation
if the flow and movements and dynamics
of the wheel
fits with describable patterns then it's
not free actually I like to make the
case that there is no semantic space
between determinism and and total
Randomness without structure and we try
to fit Free Will somewhere in between
but I think it's incoherent so for
schopenhauer the essence of the world is
will the essence of us is a will
everything is a will and by the way
there is only one wheel the one eye of
the world that looks out from Every
Creature as he he wrote it
but that will the patterns of behavior
of that will
are archetypal he he even made a
comparison to Plato's ideal forms which
was his way to say the will is not
um it's not arbitrary it's not random it
fits according to certain templates uh
that he and then in the second edition
of the world as wheel and representation
he added something to say well I
actually misrepresented Plato and then
he tried to correct that but he still
insisted on the main point which is the
will unfolds according to predictable
templates and and in that sense the
unfolding of the will is not random or
well in the way I interpret what what
Shook and I was saying I know you're an
expert on Sherman but the way I
interpret what he was saying was
basically there's a combination of Will
and representation and it's the
combination that's important so that's
what I mean by when I use the term
metaphor I mean you're putting those two
things together right so but there there
is something else there is a higher form
of determinacy I call it medicalization
sometimes that actually is determining
what happens it's not just the
representation it's not just the will
it's the two things intent
brief aside for today's sponsor nordvpn
please continue watching as doing so
supports toe for me privacy is a large
deal I'm not a fan of the tech Giants or
isps having such huge amount of
information on my IP my location nordvpn
keeps my information encrypted so I
don't have to worry about the immense
data that I have that's being put out
there being sold or even known nordvpn
also has the added benefit that if
you're jaded from the US Netflix for
example then you can switch to the UK
Netflix and it's as simple as a click of
a button you know I like referencing
Dragon Ball Z and Miyazaki well no need
to travel to Japan for your favorite
anime when nordvpn brings it directly to
you they even protect your phone's
internet usage all with one click of
their software use the link nordvpn.com
theories you'll receive a sizable
discount on the two-year plan plus one
month free on top of that all links are
in the description and the comments
what's meant by the word representation
so for schopenhauer and the wheel is the
Inner Essence of everything it's what
really exists he com he equates that to
Count's numina
um the collection of numenomes numenon
that forms existence that forms the
Universe
um and the representation is just the
outside appearance of the will if I can
quote him
the representation is how the will
presents itself can you give me an
analogy or an example
um combustion presents itself as flames
combustion is the thing in itself an
oxidation process that releases energy
forms ions leading to a plasma and what
we call Flames is how it looks like it's
what combustion looks like so for
schopenhauer all there is is Will in
other words endogenous conscious states
that that's what he means by using the
word will he means endogenous
experiences you know in other words
experiences that are not perceptual in
nature they are endogenous they arise
from within
and representation is how those
experiences present themselves to
external observation
so the world is Will
and the world presents itself to us as
the physical world which is pure
representation and for schopenhauer
causality is a as a concept applies only
to representation so only when you're
talking about the language of
representation can you talk about
causality the will behind it as the
thing in itself precedes causality but
it is not random because it follows
certain archetypal templates and he goes
on and Compares that with Plato's ideal
forms and so on so in essence
schopenhauer I think well in spirit
schopenhauer was a determinist with the
important caveat that he was a subtle
determinist he would say and he he
wouldn't say that causality is the whole
thing he would say causality is emergent
causality is something that applies to
the language of appearances not of the
things in themselves but the things in
themselves are not purely random the
house unfolding unfold according to
certain templates
um so in that sense that the spirit of
determinism is is preserved in
schopenhauer if not the letter
yes I would say that shopping hour was a
metaformal meta-determinist and I would
say that basically he was a semiotician
as well I would say that he had this
idea that there was something called
will from which a semiotic
representation emerged
emergencies of course the concept that
you've already mentioned so in in my
system in my system of metaphysics
Telesis is primary will his primary and
then it factorizes itself it actually
fractionates or factors itself into two
sides of Representative representation
which is the sign and the thing
signified by it okay plus something
called thirdness which of course is is
The Interpreter of of the sign and all
of these things three things are
combined in the ctmu in the metaformal
system by something called triality
which means that any object can be
regarded as a relation or an operation
or process you can take all of those
things at everywhere combine them so
that's that's very good yes I think that
this is something that schopenhauer was
trying to formulate but he was uh he
didn't have the mathematics at the time
you know he lived you know a long time
ago and they didn't have most of these
Concepts out there so he was unable to
Marshal them all and scrape them
together and build a system up
so that's what that's what I'm trying to
make up for is lost time due to
insufficient mathematical understanding
of what was going on with these Concepts
but the reference to to semiotics well
semiotics is language related is
something that has to do with language
that's the word semiotics that's what it
means actually they're separated used
language and semiotics semiotics is the
pure science the pure representational
information mappings that that mediate
between science and that reference right
whereas language is something that takes
those signs and puts them together in
higher order combinations
so I think for schopenhauer the wheel in
itself would not be related to signs or
or language signs and language would be
the Paradigm of the of the appearances
of the representations the the voice
telling
um not anything inherent in the will
itself the will
um for schopenhauer was beyond time and
space and therefore the distinctions
that are presupposed by semiotics
wouldn't be there in the will in itself
um those distinctions would only appear
in in the appearances in in their
representations and then language could
be applied or semiotics at first and um
in Chopin hour you you would even have
to get to what he called
um
abstract representations which was his
old-fashioned word for what we today
would call
um meta cognition it's when you you take
a sign in other words an appearance
and then you cognitively process that
sign you think about the thought or you
think about the perception and that
would be an abstract representation uh
in in Chopin hours language and language
would require that first it would
require not only representations but
abstract representations in other words
representations of representations and
now we are talking about the world of
uh semantics you know signs and their
meanings and and and and and how those
meanings are put together in a
linguistic uh structure so I'm not
contradicting what you said Chris I'm
I'm but we are talking about
schopenhauer and I feel uh a
responsibility for adding more um
yeah no problem whatsoever
um yeah I'm just saying that uh that
basically I do think that schopenhauer
was although he may not have realized it
completely he was a uh he was a must
he believed in a monarch theory in which
in which it's not it Telesis or or will
and representation are not just
dualistically linked and separated
I say that on some level he understood
that the representations have to be
coming from the world will has sometimes
yes some kind of console yes exactly not
a causal prophecy and that's more or
less what I'm talking I'm saying that
that representation is is it's a binary
mapping or binary relation and I'm
saying that to let it's like cellular
mitosis I'm saying that Telesis has to
split into those two things
while meanwhile forming itself from the
bottom Arc by two things coming together
in a physical event to particles whack
into each other as something of this
nature and that's that's basically the
metaphor concept that I'm getting at and
schopenhauer is useful in this regard
because that's what I think he was
trying to get at too
people today who think that schopenhauer
was in some sense a dualist or a dual
aspect monist I can only say they
haven't read you up an hour they didn't
they didn't even begin to read
schopenhauer because the man couldn't
have been more unambiguous more explicit
than he was in the world as wheel and
representation particularly from the
second edition on when he added you know
twice the material he kept the original
but then doubled it he repeats himself
so many times he says the same thing in
so many different ways as though to make
sure that he couldn't be misunderstood
at the battery was being paid by the
word
it's just it's surreal in Wikipedia the
other day it was still listing
schopenhauer as a Duo aspect uh theorist
uh and even the the world's uh supposed
um greatest scholar in schopenhauer uh
character from the UK called uh
Christopher Janeway
um the man just doesn't understand
schopenhauer I mean I'm sure he has
studied schopenhauer a lot but you know
intensity of study does not guarantee
understanding and the guy doesn't even
begin to understand schopenhauer he
thinks schopenhauer is a crass
materialist and it's absurd I don't
think I read some of your comments on on
January
about I know you wrote a book on
showpenauer yeah a few years ago yeah
but you also wrote an essay I think that
accompanied the book or was a some kind
of a prequel to The Book right in which
you would talk did talk about this
Fellowship anyway yeah yeah
I've been trying to bait him for a while
but he doesn't take debate he's wiser
[Music]
okay let's talk about talk about free
will it seems like that's what is at the
core here so I'll do so by reading a
question which is directed toward Chris
but then obviously if you pull something
out even though it has some terminology
that's specific to the ctmu Bernardo
please comment on it as well okay hey
Kurt I'm reposting this from YouTube
it's for Chris on the topic of Free Will
derived from the ctmu if you can ask
this you'll forever be my hero you once
said I believe he's referring to you
Chris Chris you said that the universe
but because the universe is only itself
to Define itself everything in it must
exemplify its Elementary freedom I think
I understand from your defining reality
as as all real influence that reality
cannot be abbreviated because if you
were able to simplify it with no loss
whatever was removed could not logically
have been real I understand where to
take this to imply that reality could
not have come from anything simpler than
its full definition and what can't be
simplified must be contributory
throughout that said you've still
maintained a strong distinction between
tertiary syntactors
objects and secondary syntactors slash
tellers life forms read life forms in
terms of
the amount that they are determinative
considering that you've shown that
reality is a mind
could we liken the distinction to the
difference between ideas of objects and
ideas of self where just like ideas all
objects have some significance specific
to them however seemingly but now but
only tellers as ideas of self would be
self-modeling and therefore truly take
on self-awareness that's why they're
called tellers that's why self
type identity operators are called
pillows whereas tertiary identity
operators are fermionic more or less and
they are inanimate or at least usually
considered to be inanimate but basically
they're embedded in secondary tellers
and therefore they take that higher
order metacausation that that ability to
self the model from the secondary
tolerance so I assume you're answering
the question right now but Chris I
didn't understand the question so can
you explain the question back to myself
and then answer it well it states you
know there's no such thing as a state in
isolation states are always relatively
defined that's why we have theories of
Relativity and things but what must the
state be defined relative to well any to
completely define any state in the
universe you need to refer to every
other state in the universe because it
parameterizes that statement okay and
you don't get a complete
parameterization unless you have the
full matter distribution and the full
metric okay so that's what it takes
can I see if I can I make an analogy
there's a duality between a set and the
complement of a set assuming that the
set is within some other large set that
you can call right so let's say the
large status s you have a subset U then
there's a duality between you and you
with a c which is the complement of it
the teller and the environment right
exactly self and nonsense
okay sorry continue okay well the
environment of course is just the medium
minus the total or in other words the
what is external to the median but it's
outside the boundary of the uh of the
telhor and so you get this basically
this self-deal the self-dual construct
which is a telor environment coupling
okay and this tell our environment
coupling is very important to the ctme
because that's kind of a metaformal
point it's one way of expressing ctmu
quantization okay you have to put the
medium together with the object
the object is its own median through
through this process called conspension
which is the operation through which the
universe evolves on the global level now
in order to get semantic meaning out of
that you know basically it's basically
it's called Cosmic expense
to get meaning out of that then you need
another process called tele recursion
which then specifies it has semantic
structure through the syntactic
structure that's built up by cost
fashion
Chris it's been almost a year since I
studied the ctmu and when I did I didn't
go back to it which means I've forgotten
so much of it so much of the terminology
as I would have done myself okay so much
of the terminology it goes through me so
italic recursion I have a vague
recollection that it's where the
universe exercises free will it looks at
some generalized utility State and then
makes a decision that's where tellur is
self-configure this was secondary
identity operators or teller was
self-configured they actually become the
media
okay and I know that uh Bernardo
actually Embraces something like this
and is uh his analytic idealism I think
is what he calls okay basically you've
got to have that going
okay so let me be blunt so free will in
your theory and your model Chris exists
and Bernardo if I'm correct you're
against the idea of free will at least
currently well let me tell you what free
will is first person okay
yes uh as I said there is no
typographical array in the metaphor
system okay you can't use the parameter
as a state you cannot just use a a fixed
array a fixed array the array has to be
changing geometric uh geometry
dynamically is the term that uh that
they followers of Einstein came up with
to describe what must be going on it's
happening behind the scenes okay Free
Will happens because things are
determined metacosly you know and
metaformally which means that that that
things have to be coupled or factorized
right in other words it's just not this
linear process this causal process but
it's this high order process called
medicalization that is occurred and this
is free will
if we look at a conspensive cycle in the
ctmu it's an alpha omega cycle in other
words it starts in an orgs and it ends
with the boundary and those two things
are in advanced and [ __ ]
communication with each other
right Free Will is in determining one of
those consequence of Cycles regardless
of what it says
so in other words I do there is a there
is a way to define free will that gets
out of this pseudo-costal dichotomy
between the terminacy and indeterminacy
that we were talking about earlier
right in other words you're creating the
media you're actually creating space
time as you create a new state
right when you bring that new mental
state into your head you've actually
done it by creating space time
all right this is a this is a kind of a
very profound very weird way of looking
at it I understand but it sounds weird
but it's the only way in my opinion
things can work um I I recommend more
generically because I'm not familiar
with the Chris's terminology so it's
it's impossible for me to to go into the
details of that but um you you offered
uh Kurt that I am currently against free
will there's a lot of nuance to this so
let me try to to clarify this if the the
question of Free Will is linked to a
materialist metaphysics
um like people worrying that oh if my
choices are determined by the patterns
of brain activity in my brain uh then I
don't have free will well on that
account I think people need not
be afraid because I don't think
physiological patterns of brain activity
cause your choices I think they are what
your choices look like in schopenhauer's
terminology the their appearances
representations the thing in itself is
your choice so no your choices are not
determined by your brain activity your
brain activities what's the process of
making choices look like and then you
would say well then I am endorsing Free
Will well now we have now to understand
what people mean by Free Will what
people mean by it is that their choices
are determined by that which they
identify themselves with
as opposed to being determined by
something that they don't identify with
and most people don't identify with
their brain activity they never get to
see it they don't identify with it
that's why when when a physicalist says
wow your choices are determined by your
brain activity people feel that as a
violation of their free will because
they identify with their own mental
processes the the flow of their
Consciousness not with physical patterns
of bringing activity inside their skull
which they which they never saw in their
lives
um now let's think about the mind of
nature
the mind of nature is the only thing
there is
so need and and Will are the same thing
there is nothing I mean
I I have to work right I'm forced by my
Society to work so my choice to work is
not freely determined by me it's a need
imposed on me by the society and I don't
identify with the rest of the society so
my Free Will has been cut short in that
regard but if you are the mind of nature
there is no Society there is no world
outside of you there's nothing Beyond
you
so whatever choices you make as the mind
of nature are free in the sense that
they are determined but they are
determined by you
you see your notification exactly yeah
the need and the choice are that are one
and the same there is no semantic
difference between determinism and Free
Will at the level of the mind of nature
because yes the choices are determined
even people who believe in free will
they are not saying that their choices
are random they're saying that their
choices are determined by their
preferences their tastes they are
determined by them
at the level of the mind of nature every
choice is determined by the mind of
nature because there is nothing beyond
the universal mind the universal
Consciousness so even the question of
Free Will disappears there is a semantic
space for it it doesn't make sense to
talk about it but
the choices are still determined
in the sense that they are not random
the choices of the mind of nature are
determined by what the mind of nature is
its characteristics its properties
determine the choices it makes it cannot
abstract of itself otherwise the choices
would be completely random and that's
incoherent to say that right yeah I
would merely add that we what we have to
do is we have to distinguish Free Will
what's happening there from determinacy
and non-determinacy okay so with it is
useful to talk about free will just to
distinguish it from what we usually mean
by causation and once we do that then we
find out that we can describe it in a
certain way
right in terms of this conspiration and
teleprecursion saying what I was talking
about earlier
I think ultimately everything is
determined even your choices are
determined by your tastes by your
dispositions you know your opinion your
class your question imagine just imagine
the origin of reality what determined
the structure of reality in other words
there was nothing outside really
according to general relativity
basically reality is quantically and
geometrically closed okay so there's
nothing else so there's no there's no
extrinsic
it's a conversation that could have
caused the universe to take any
particular form so aren't we talking
about the universe taking its own form
somehow deciding within itself what form
it should take
deciding within itself can only happen
if that decision is determined by what
it is
yes but what decides who decides what it
is
nobody at the end of the day at the
bottom level of nature something exists
that cannot be explained in terms of
anything else we cannot explain one
thing in terms of another forever it
doesn't matter what metaphysics one
subscribes to reality we cannot keep on
reducing forever otherwise you
eventually you will go back to the
beginning and it will be a circular
reasoning
unless it's not important that actually
applies to themselves you don't get to
the top of the ladder you just keep on
going from run to run to run and each
rung is identical to the last group
right and then it's some form of
infinite regress no at the end of no the
item potency says that it stays the same
you're not regressing anyway okay it's
just it reaches a static point of
Maximum generalization and then it holds
steady it doesn't make any difference
yeah you're going the other way around
now I'm thinking about reduction I'm
going down to the bottom there has to be
something at the bottom that simply is
it simply is what it is now earlier
yeah now earlier you said
um for something to exist it needs to
have properties to say that something is
an object means that it has properties
so to be is to have properties I agree
with you there to be is to have
properties whatever it is that you are
you are one thing and not another in
other words there are properties
Associated to your beingness now
whatever there is at the end of the
chain of reduction the bottom line of
nature it just is and therefore it has
properties
everything that it does is then
determined by its properties it's
determined by what it is
as opposed to what it is not or to what
it could have been so even the mind of
nature is is a mind that has properties
I mean we're not attaching any you're
not attaching any properties to this
ultimate reduction that you're talking
about so in that but you're saying and
yet everything with the universe is is
somehow determined by it I don't think
that's you know quite kosher I think
that we have to actually try to attach
some properties to it in order
I just had to be is to have properties
so whatever there is at the bottom level
of the chain of reduction it has
properties now we may not know directly
self-assigned properties right yes
intrinsic not self-assigned it's it's
intrinsic to the beingness of the thing
to be is to have properties but against
what background are we are we
distinguishing those properties the
background of what could have been so
the lawsuits are what they are so
gravity makes objects fall we could live
in a universe in which a gravity pulls
objects up it's a it's a repellent as
opposed to an attractor now that's not
what is the laws of nature are what they
are are as opposed to what they could
have been in our imagination so whatever
nature is it has properties and that's
why objects fall in static electricity
is produced when you rub Amber to to to
to to to to a cloth cloth so
this stuff that is I understand
everything that you're saying okay let's
see but if it had properties then those
properties had negations and something
had to distinguish those properties from
indications
okay otherwise it is useless to talk
about them having properties at all
there's got to be the property there's
going to be the The Logical complement
of that property and something has to be
doing the logic of it all for us to for
for reality itself for Ultimate Reality
to perceive what its properties are or
to act as though those properties exist
you follow me that something is us and
our ability to conceive of nature being
different than what it is and we are
parts of reality where sensor control is
for reality as a whole so that's our
function
to conceive of what could have been in
theory or
after consuming that to conceive of what
is yeah yeah but I'm trying to speak of
something even much simpler than we are
getting to right now what I'm trying to
say is the following wherever there is
at the chain of reduction it has
properties and Its Behavior is
determined by the properties it has in
other words the behavior of nature is
determined by what nature is as opposed
to anything else we could conceive
nature to be
so ultimately everything is determined
it ought to be determined otherwise we
just throw science and then down down
that's a that's a tautology you're not
actually we're looking for something
when you see determined I'm looking for
a causal dependency I'm looking for a
cause and an effect of some kind okay
that's what you're talking about the
same right right okay so that what we're
talking about however is a tautology
everything is intense not yes it is it
has to be it's everything is intrinsic
because reality is optically closed
there is nothing outside of reality that
is real enough to affect reality
it's a logical contradiction to disagree
with that what I said is not a tautology
it's not a tautology what I'm saying is
that
of all things that nature could
conceivably have been it is what it is
and not anything else
properties and those properties
determine what happens so the universe
expands as opposed to collapsing because
the properties of the universe are such
that they cause the universe to expand I
agree so you can speak of causation in
the language of representation in that
sense without being tautological and if
we speak of Minds then we have to
abandon well we have to say but I'm
trying to yes yes I'm trying to get down
to the properties that you are ascribing
to Ultimate Reality reality is what it
is as you say you're 100 right about
that but what are its properties and how
do things happen because of those
preferences so I'm trying to get to that
to that so we've been speaking with the
language of schopenhauer's
representations the physical world and
Science and causation but you and I
agree that at the end of the day there
is only one mind one business so what is
the language of the will how do we
describe what I'm saying in the language
of the will of the thing in itself well
Jung gave us the language Jung talked
about the archetypes which are this
intrinsic primordial templates of mental
behavior and those templates are
intrinsic they are there because mind is
what it is
and if nature is a mind then then the
archetypes of nature are those
properties so you don't think the mind
is conditioned to have those properties
you don't think there's anything wrong
okay you think the mind just is what it
is
to be is to have properties and I'm
saying those properties are the
archetypes in jungian Psychology applied
to the collective unconsciousness
applied to a mind that is not a
individual mind okay so you realize you
were assigning a property there
but that's what I'm saying Chris I'm
saying that to be is to have properties
yes I would agree with that and it's
also to have values or instances
so that way it's self-doule you don't
have to separate the instances from the
properties
okay and if you you can call reality an
instance of itself and that's the
tautology that I'm talking about
okay so I call it a super tautology it's
not I I don't know why you're saying
this I don't know what you're talking
about to be honest I don't know what
you're talking about instances of itself
reality is what it is to be is to have
properties those properties are what we
could call archetypes templates of
behavior of mind and that's why nature
behaves the way it does because it has
whatever archetypes it does have
existing nature instantiates those
properties you're assigning or
distributing properties to Nature and
the nature is instantiating the
properties am I right
if you want to speak the language of
mathematics you can speak that way I'm
not sure how helpful it is to the
audience it's very it's very helpful
because that's what a super tautology is
it's it's something that is its own
properties and its own instances
why do we speak of instances if there is
only one thing I don't think this
language is helpful at all it's
obscurantism well it's with all due
respect it's not just obscurantism there
are instances of properties out there
you are an instance of the properties
that make up Bernardo okay I'm an insta
an instance of the properties that make
up Chris and likewise for Kurt yeah but
Chris and Bernardo exists in a broader
context but the mind of nature is what
there is there is there is nothing else
so twice why to speak of instances I'm
not arguing against you there I I'd be
the last person in the world to argue
with you about that I'm just trying to
pin down some of these properties that
we're ascribing to Ultimate or basic
reality once you get all the way down to
the bottom of the reduction as you said
then there's got to be something there
what is it so now we're we're stuck you
see we have to say Okay well whatever it
is it's part of reality therefore
reality goes in a circle it's this big
self-defined loop
right that's so that's my
you follow that fair enough okay fair
enough now do we know what those
properties are directly of course not
um we know
what results from those properties the
behavior of the universe results from
those properties or those archetypes
whatever those intrinsic properties are
um and it turns out that the behavior of
nature is regular fairly predictable so
I would say that they are determined by
those properties which we don't know
directly but we can infer that they
exist because nature behaves in a fairly
regular and predictable way do you think
that we do you think that we have
anything to do with determining any of
those properties
the properties are what they are by
virtue of the fact that the universe is
what it is and we are part of the
universe so we don't determine them we
are determined by them well could there
be a reciprocity there I mean could
there be they determine us and then we
determine them back I don't think so I
think if you're talking about the most
innate properties
then they are the properties of what
there is they are what they are because
the universe is what it is now we could
we could determine meta Properties or we
could play a role in the the causal
unfolding that derives from those
properties yes that we could do but I
don't think there we go and by
participating in that unfold you you
mean we're just like passive things that
allow properties to emerge through us
but have nothing to do with creating the
properties themselves I'm talking about
the fundamental properties now you could
talk about the properties at many levels
that are not fundamental of course like
human beings have properties but those
are not the fundamental properties of
the universe or or black holes have
properties but those are not the
fundamental properties of the universe
at the the bottom of the chain of
causation and you don't see yourself as
implicated at all in in actually
configuring those larger properties
those secondary derivative properties
yes of course we are part of the
unfolding dynamics of the universe so
now if you if you detonate a nuclear
bomb on the moon will change the
properties of the the moon yeah we can
influence that that's trivial trivially
so but I was talking about the bottom
level fundamental properties of
existence I don't think we can change
those for the same reason that a human
being can't change it his or her own
mental archetypes those are inherent to
the beingness of the Universe I I agree
I agree with almost everything you said
except for you seem to be saying okay it
just is that's it and I'm saying maybe
we can actually reach in there and
induce some properties some actual
specific properties that lead to this
whole thing being structured the way it
is
uh well I I commented on that already so
I think it's clear hopefully
okay well that you seem to be saying the
universe is meta deterministic
or super duty I don't know what you mean
by that so I cannot say yes or no but
maybe maybe well you say that the
structure of the universe is determined
by what it is and what its properties
are
all right what it is and what's prop
what its properties are are the same
thing said in two different ways well
yes but there's also an extension with
the with the intention the intention is
the properties now we need the instances
as well
those are the things that the properties
intersect in oh you know if you could
talk about a red heavy object okay and
then you can take a cannonball and paint
it red that's an instance instantiating
both of those properties right the
properties don't refer to each other
heavy isn't red and red isn't heavy
right but if we have instances then we
can make the properties interact
so we need both of those things and I'm
just saying that they're metformally
coupled and that's what we do in the ctm
unit
I think you're I think you're very
insightful and I think we agree on
almost everything but there are a couple
of sticking points here otherwise it
wouldn't really be a theologution would
it
last brief aside for today's sponsor
manscaped you may have noticed that in
brown and what's concomitant with being
Brown is being hairy that's why I'm
happy that support for theories of
everything is brought to you by
manscaped who's number one in Men's
Grooming below the waist there's also an
ear and nose trimmer which I use and
happily sew as you can see the package I
have is the performance package 4.0 it
comes with crop preserver and crop
reviver which are male genitalia
deodorant and toner respectively if you
thought condoms were difficult to ask
for well try asking the 65 year old lady
behind the counter for what will improve
your gonad's texture luckily you don't
have to since manscaped is online this
package even comes with this shirt which
I wear pretty much exclusively to the
gym I may not be able to bench the most
but I can pretty much guarantee that I'm
the most testicularly hygienic get 20
off and free shipping with the code
everything20 at manscaped.com that's 20
off with shipping at manscaped.com using
the code everything20 unlock your
confidence and always use the right
tools for the job with manscaped let's
get to this with a more mythological
question are Jesus and Buddha attempting
to answer the same problem but from
different perspectives are they
answering different problems are there
answers their teachings whatever they
may be are they commensurate though on
the surface at least to me they
contradict
there's quite a few questions there
Bernardo if you don't mind starting that
off
I I'm
I'm not a religious studies specialist
so you have to take anything and
everything I'm about to say with the
enormous grain of salt maybe a whole bag
of it I have a good friend who is a
specialist Jeffrey crippo if Jeff is
listening to this I hope he will not
cringe with what I'm about to say
um
I think they are they were trying to
answer the same question
and I think if you penetrate beyond the
surface of appearances and different
metaphors and symbols and the different
languages they spoke you know there is a
difference of 500 years between them and
a difference in geographies as well so
if you can penetrate beyond all that and
look at the essence of their answers I
think it was essentially the same answer
actually there are serious studies and
there's a serious academic opinion that
Christianity in fact may be derived from
Buddhism there is even speculation about
where Jesus might have been during that
time between his 12th year and his 30th
year right
for now huh do you mean vetism
or are you do you really mean that
Christianity was drought for Buddhism
Christianity derives from Buddhism
that's that's one academic opinion that
has been put forward there's even
speculation that Jesus who was in India
during that time of his life where the
Bible says nothing about him
um I think the questions the fundamental
question they were both trying to answer
is
what is the relation between
us as human beings and the Universe At
Large what is that relationship Jung put
it in the following words
are we related to something Transcendent
to something infinite or not that that
is in the gazillion dollar question are
we related to something infinite or not
and I think they both were trying to
answer this question that relationship
between us as individual individuals and
the Universe At Large existence at large
what is that relationship because we
take the cue for our behavior from our
tentative answer to that question our
our inner narrative about what that
relation is
um and I wouldn't I would even go as far
and and to say that they they gave the
same answer
um
when Jesus talked of himself as the son
of God
he was talking about a fundamental
kinship between a human being and the
divinity
a fundamental kinship now the son of the
father is of the same kind as the father
bear Force because it's something that
came from the father and he also
emphasized the need
to
surrender
the direction of Our Lives to a greater
power
and if that's not Buddhism what is it
Buddhism is the surrender of the ego is
seen through the illusion of personal
identity individual identity
um it is connecting to a greater mental
context a greater cognitive context so I
think in essence yes they were both
saying the same thing and then
600 years later a little bit more there
came the prophet
and said the same thing and that's why
Muslims bow to a greater power five
times a day which I think is a is a
fantastic ritual it's a daily reminder
that our lives are not about us our
lives are about
something much bigger than us they're in
line the meaning of Our Lives
um and the kinship in Christianity
between Jesus and us is also there
explicit when when the Holy Ghost
descends into every righteous man woman
and child
and remember the Holy Ghost is Jesus so
when the Holy Ghost descends not only
into the apostles but every righteous
human being what is being said is that
there is a direct kingship between you
and the Son of God and of course a
direct kinship between between the Son
of God and the godhead
um it's a real it's a hierarchy of
kinships so to say of of identical kinds
um which basically tell us that we are
leafs in a great tree and and existence
is about the tree not about the leaves
imagine if the blossom of my apple tree
in my backyard in the spring would say
my life's about me I should take the
reins of My Life as a blossom because my
life's about me well we would laugh at
the Little Flower because no it's not
about the flower it's about the tree
it's about the fruit that will come
after the flower is gone and the tree
that will come from the fruit after the
fruit is is gone it's about a much
bigger context and I think that's the
message of Christianity and Buddhism the
need to surrender
ourselves to the greater directions of
existence and understand that it's not
about us has never been and will never
be and we do not need to invest
ourselves with this crushing
responsibility of manufacturing meaning
for our lives it's a necessary meaning
is intrinsic as long as you are in touch
with the movements of the impersonal
within us
we are in touch with meaning it's just
that we've become blind to it because of
the crazy narratives of our current
civilization
Chris
well I I agree with a lot of that very
poetic thank you Bernardo
um there is uh the primary issue is the
relationship between man and reality the
Ultimate Reality which is God
and uh to Christians anyway and I think
that it's productive to formulate this
this uh question in terms of the goal of
life
now in in Buddhism the goal of life is
nirvana Chief Nirvana for the vedics it
was mugshot okay and for the Christians
it is salvation those are distinct
Concepts all right the the two of them
have to do with completely extricating
yourself from samsara you know the cycle
of birth and death and rebirth you
extricate yourself completely from that
and totally free yourself from the world
that exists what Christ was trying to
tell people is that you cannot extricate
yourself from God from the world that
exists you what you you have moral
responsibility you know here are your
moral responsibilities they're
enumerated in the Ten Commandments etc
etc and here's the Golden Rule so now
you've got a mathematical law of moral
symmetry that you can apply to the whole
thing so they're really in some respects
the answers are the same they give an
answer for what is the relationship
between man and reality but in other
respects they're very different
okay we have a moral responsibility to
our fellow human beings and through
reality and to God in Christianity
whereas in Buddhism it's not quite the
same thing there is some of that of
course there's a an equivalent to
morality in Buddhism and vetism now that
being said I mean that's uh I'm the
shove Buddhism aside for a second just
talk about that is you know and and if
you take a look at Buddhism and then you
take a look at Christian neoplatonism uh
as as uh set forth by platinus for
example and other you know people like
him you find that they're very very soon
you've got this this Vedic model where
you've you know you've got Brahman and
then from Brahman you come down to mind
and then from mind you go down to the
world right this is basically what
neoplatonism is okay and neoplatonism of
course was very popular among these
Scholastics medieval Christians right
and basically what they were doing was
they were embracing something very much
like vetism
so that's what we're that's that's these
are things that we have to observe when
we're trying to compare
these separate religions and what
they're all talking about okay great a
Christian says that well our job is to
achieve salvation we do that by moral
goodness okay Buddhism says much the
same thing okay you've gotta you know
you've got uh you've got this uh you've
got Dharma which is righteousness and
then you go from uh from righteousness
into Moksha Buddha was a little bit more
he was less uh less prescriptive about
these things right I mean there's
there's there are degrees of freedom in
Buddhism you know it's very very popular
because it seems to
um limit your moral responsibility
whereas this is something that Jesus and
and the Hindus were not necessarily
interested in doing there is this moral
responsibility it's inescapable and
that's that
Bernardo are you champing at the bit
uh but I just have him smoke I'm not
sure it's even worthwhile to mention it
but I I agree with with Chris that
medieval Scholars from before the 11th
century
um they flirted with neoplatonism John
scotus origena was one of them
um but the Scholastics and race star is
total and try to root out neoplatonism
but but okay it's it's just a small
small detail
well there are nevertheless similar
Aristotle didn't really have anything
comparable to what we're talking about
so it was the neoplatonics or else they
you know this idea of the one and then
you go down from the one to noose right
to nous I don't know how it's pronounced
um and then you come down from there
into the world now what I have what I've
found is that you've been liking this
whole this whole thing to a reality self
simulation which can actually be
mathematically in scientifically
described
okay in other words there's this this
emanation this series of emanations that
leads to what we are in this world and
when we die then we are retracted into
this bundle of emanations and then we
you know it may be possible to re-emerge
into another world the heaven hell a new
life
whatever you may call it all right but
there's enough structure there that I
think we've got some very interesting
possibilities
okay here's a set of questions that
comes from Charlie ifra where did the
assumption that Consciousness is good
come from where did the assumption that
Consciousness matters come from where do
the assumption that Consciousness makes
us special come from why don't we assume
that Consciousness is just something we
do and it's no more special than
eyesight or scent so I'm going to send
this in the chat because it's a set of
questions that are similar but it's
probably useful to refer to okay well
the Consciousness is basically primitive
okay it's a primitive property Bernardo
was talking earlier about the properties
what reality is consciousness is a
primitive property of reality okay it
has to be conscious there's got to be
this feedback that I was talking about
doing this tele feedback between past
and future all right that's what allows
us to get out of this pseudo dichotomy
that we're talking about so
Consciousness is primitive it is there
it is what it is nobody has to say
anything about it nobody has to
pronounce it this or make assumptions
about it it is what it is it's there it
distributes over reality in different
forms that are appropriate to the
circumstances in which under which it
emerges okay a tiny little particle an
electron has Consciousness in a certain
way all right and then a teller a
secondary an organism has Consciousness
in another way okay then we get up to
Big Brain human beings we have a higher
kind of self-modeling Consciousness
still then we get all the way up to God
that has all of these forms of
Consciousness at once right so
Consciousness is absolutely intrinsic to
the nature of the universe and we
needn't make any assumptions about its
importance or its Primacy or anything
else Bernard you want to tackle let me
tackle them one by one where did the
assumption that Consciousness is
important come from I don't know I don't
make that assumption I know that
Consciousness is it is all I have
ultimately so if that's not important
then probably nothing is which may be a
valid answer but I don't make that
assumption where did the assumption that
Consciousness is good come from I don't
know I don't make that assumption
Consciousness is whether it's good or
bad no
determine on a case-by-case basis I
think there is as many good reasons to
think that Consciousness has bad in it
as there are reasons to think that it
has good in it
uh where did the assumption that
Consciousness matters come from he's
streaming everything as if it were an
assumption well I don't know but if
conscious Consciousness doesn't matter
then what does because we are cooped up
in Consciousness at all times so if that
doesn't matter then nothing does
for where did the assumption that
Consciousness makes a special come from
I don't know I don't make that
assumption I don't think it makes us
special I think Consciousness permeates
the whole of existence so we are not
special on that account because it's
just something that permeates the whole
of existence not only us
and five why don't we assume that
Consciousness is just something we do
because it's not a question of
assumption it's a question of theorizing
coherently so our theories stand up to
reason and to the evidence so you can
assume that I don't know that your
Consciousness is the sun good luck with
that but it that's not the game we are
playing we are not playing the game of
arbitrary assumptions we are playing the
game of trying to find the most coherent
empirically tenable internally
consistent most explanatory powerful
narrative or model or theory about
what's going on and the most coherent
and explanatory powerful the one that
avoids most problems all problems
arguably is that Consciousness is
fundamental it's not an assumption it's
a consequence of a careful line of
reasoning and an investigation of the
evidence
and and the source of that line and the
source and medium of that line of
reasoning we should have everything you
said is 100 right but but it's it's not
just a consequence okay it is the origin
as well it's right there it's it's all
distributed throughout the entire
process of relation or conference
there's no escape from it
okay go ahead yeah sorry Bernardo
Bernardo why is it that you call your
theory analytical idealism what's what's
the difference between some other
account of idealism and yours there's
nothing new in this this stuff has been
put forward by many people for thousands
of years I think there is a perfectly
good word in history called idealism uh
that that's what I'm talking about so
why will I use another word but under
pressure
to differentiate what I'm talking about
from say
Barclays idealism which I think is
flawed
um I needed to add a qualifier
and because I arrived at idealism from
a a rational investigation that holds up
to the values of analytic philosophy the
philosophy that was being stated you
know by veteran Russell in the 1920s
Wittgenstein and others that's that say
no you have to be a conceptually
explicit and coherent you have to avoid
ambiguity you cannot be internally
inconsistent and you have to ground
everything in empirical evidence so I I
espouse all that I espouse the values of
analytic philosophy not to the detriment
of Continental philosophy but next to
those I espouse the values of analytic
philosophy and I defend my ideal
idealism in a way that can only be
characterized as analytical you know
based on the values of the analytic
philosophy school that's why I call it
analytic idealism it's it's my very best
effort to not come up with new words but
to stick to Old words so people know
that I'm not saying anything you at all
here
okay uh can I ask a question I mean
analytic basically means having to do
with Concepts and language so somehow in
other words you're talking about the
language you use is just more careful
than it is an ordinary dialogue you're
actually theorizing very carefully and
that's how language enters into this is
that would that be accurate that's fair
enough that would be the reason why
Russell chose the word analytic
philosophy back then so I'm just using
the word he used if he had used another
word I would be using that word instead
well then we have the kantian meaning
too which refers to tautology
and then basically your predicate is
implicit in your subject or vice versa
my usage of analytic in analytic
philosophy is a reference sorry my use
of analytic in analytic idealism is a
reference to analytic in analytic
philosophy so I'm basically linking it
to analytic philosophy because I make my
argument according to the style and
value system of analytic philosophy I
understand if they had chosen the word X
philosophy I would be saying X ideally
so we talked about this but didn't use
the word non-dualism and many people in
the non-dualist community would say that
love is fundamental that Consciousness
is fundamental but love is too and
somehow those are the same or somehow
love is more fundamental than
Consciousness okay
explain to someone as confused as myself
what you make of that how does that make
sense how can love be fundamental What
is love
Bernardo if you don't mind well I I I
never said that love is fundamental no
I'm not saying you did it I apologize if
I said that I'm saying some non-dualists
I'm sure you've heard you didn't say
that I'm just I'm just emphasizing it
for for clarity and lack of ambiguity I
think love is a particular pattern of
excitation of Consciousness fear is
another so if love is fundamental so is
fear
um and so is I I don't know delight and
and any any other emotion so from that
perspective I think it is subjectivity
that is fundamental not to the
particular excitation of subjectivity
that we describe with words such as love
fear and all the other emotions
um so I think empirically if I if I look
at nature
I don't see compelling reason to think
that love is somehow
more
primordial or more fundamental than fear
than than evil because you see this
stuff all around the nature I mean
animals are killing each other slowly
and painfully so they can survive it's a
bloodbath volcanoes erupt and millions
of animals are killed in very painful
circumstances it's not a pretty picture
so I I don't particularly
see a reason to prioritize
love over over anything else I mean
Dante wrote about the love that moves
the Son and the other stars suggesting
that you know what what we see as stars
is
um is the representation of love the
external appearance of love and that
stars in and of themselves experience
themselves as an outpouring of love that
may be but then black holes are the
opposite right because instead of
irradiating they suck everything in and
I see no reason to say that stars are
more
fundamental than black holes as a matter
of fact we know black holes form when
stars collapse into themselves
um so no I I no no I'm afraid I don't
see love as as fundamental I see
subjectivity phenomenal Consciousness as
fundamental and I would love if love
were fundamental I would love it
um but I I don't see good reasons to
think that it is no why would you love
it if it was fundamental
well because now we would feel all all
fuzzy and warm
and protected and safe
um but I don't think there is good
reason to think that I think
what
and now I'm speculating and I'm
speculating without Authority here so
take it with a with a bag of salt I
think what some spiritual teachers I
think what motivates them to say that
love is fundamental is that um there is
a phase during meditation or during a
psychedelic experience
you pass through a threshold
right around
the ego dissolution phase when you sort
of shed personal identity there's a lot
of fear with that but then you land tend
to to land in a place for a little while
where you sort of remember
and what you remember I can't put in
English I can't put in any there are no
words for what you remember so I can't
say but you remember and that
remembrance feel like a reconnection
with your own umbilical cord with your
own home your own
source and it feels very warm and loving
that remembrance that that reconnection
with your roots
but is a transitory phase uh if if you
persist in that then even that is shared
even that feeling of Love fuzzy coziness
you know remembrance back home even that
is shadowy uh as just one more phase of
experience but nothing fundamental and
then you go somewhere else
and I'm not going to talk about that
somewhere else but I can imagine that if
you have not visited the deeper levels
in the Palace of mind you just went one
level lower one or two level lower then
you would say well I found love there so
Love Is Fundamental I I can clearly see
that happening but then I would think
arrogantly maybe that well we just
haven't gone deep enough because below
that there is stuff that you wouldn't
call love
Chris would it be all right if I asked
Bernardo one more question and then if
you want if there's anything that comes
to mind just take a note and then
so that's fun okay great so Bernardo in
some of the conferences I'm sure that
you've attended on spirituality and
non-dualism
there seems to be a special place for
love and there seems to be a special
place for fear namely that one is to
shed fear and that almost all of
suffering if not all of suffering comes
from fear and for me just to get my
point of view across it doesn't seem
completely correct unless they're using
a different definition of fear because
there are people who have a part of
their brain that's that they lack
there's a
there's a disconnection in some part of
their brain they don't actually
experience fear and it's deleterious
it's not good for them they stand too
close to people they are more likely to
get into fights they have to be watched
over and there's also sociopathy which
is related to a lack of fear but social
fear so it doesn't seem to me that one
should just shed all of one's fear in
order to live more peaceably well maybe
in order to live more peaceably but that
existence doesn't persist for a while
and it also doesn't seem to be good for
the other people around you
either way that's my thoughts on it
do you see the same distinction between
love and fear like there's a special
place for fear namely we should shed it
and what are your thoughts on that
so I'll give you a personal opinion this
this is not grounded on my work as a
philosopher or my previous work as a
scientist so I'm not sure my opinion
should count more than anybody else's
opinion
um but I sympathize with what you said I
think there is a place for fear there is
a reason we've evolved to feel fearful I
mean in certain circumstances it is
healthy it's it helps preserve your your
own safety I think what
what may be
um is trying to be
expressed in those conferences is that
you shouldn't be in the grip of fear
fear shouldn't control your life and
unfortunately that's what happens a lot
in our civilization that fear instead of
being just one more ingredient in this
great Melting Pot of emotions that we
carry along through life that fear
becomes the dominating force and I have
experience with that I have suffered
from anxiety and fear can make your
world very small it can make you blind
to everything else it can destroy your
ability to empathize it can destroy your
ability to tune into what's happening
around you destroys your ability to
enjoy the present moment because your
mind is always in that narrative making
of what might happen that could be very
bad for you so not surrendering control
to fear I think is important but
eliminating fear altogether I think
that's like cutting a limb it's it's
it's uh it's taking away a part of your
own Humanity if you become unable to
feel fear how will you empathize with
the ukrainians now so you know
surrendering to fear eliminates empathy
but destroying fear completely
eliminates empathy as well because you
become unable to relate to what other
people are going through and you become
less human and and I don't think that's
the game to play I think the game to
play is to mature our own Humanity to
its full and fear is certainly an
ingredient of that there is nothing I
think a priori bad about fear the only
bad thing is when you have an imbalance
and nothing balance can be an excess of
fear or even a lack of fear I think the
point is is a balance and I see I I
understand these conferences when they
aim they put emphasis on reducing fear
because in our civilization in our
society today most of the times we are
not in balance and the imbalance is
precisely an excess of fear so that's
where you put the emphasis you try to
reduce that which is excessive but I
don't think it should be extrapolated to
the point of rooting out fear altogether
then you're not human you will be a
mutilated human being that's not
something to desire at least I don't I
don't desire that
okay so Chris there's plenty that was
said and if you want to comment on any
of it please do I'll restate the
original question which is essentially
well what is love and what's its
relationship to what's fundamental
well love it's all about uh
identification and identity obviously
reality identifies with itself there's
no not necessarily any emotion attached
to that but in order to make this work
in in the world uh reality configures
itself as syntax there's a kind of
syntax in the metaformal system called
the ETS for emotelic syntax
emotions like fear and love can form you
of a need that's basically what they do
they're telling you there's a deficit of
utility in your life and that you need
to fill it and this is what causes you
to configure yourself as a tell-on and
then affect causation
all right until it brings together
causation in certain ways by certain
mechanisms and this is actually what
happens there is no way to do without
things like fear and love as far as love
is concerned the love between you two
human beings is concerned they love each
other and they feel that wonderful
emotion because of the ETS those those
feelings the moods they come out of the
this this particular kind of of this
quality that has been put in your mind
by reality itself so that it can survive
so it can renew its identity over and
over and over again two people who are
on love are basically they want to unite
they want to merge their identities in
one destiny one shared Destiny that's
what love is so love starts out as a as
an extremely fundamental property of
reality then creates the ETS which then
causes us to behave in certain ways that
cause us to unite our Destinies and do
things like Marian have children which
reality needs in order to renew the
cycle of Life what's the ETS
the emotec syntax
the most standing for emotion and teleco
course meaning basically emotion you
experience emotions because they are
usually most emotions because they are
informing you of some kind of need you
have a need that their fear means the
need to fight fight or flee okay love
means the need to you know to care for
or nurture and procreate okay and and
you can attach this to to virtually
anything basically this is the part of
our minds that tells us what we need and
then we configure ourselves telegram by
means of teleconcursion or
teleconization configure ourselves to
fulfill those needs and it's like a
charge system on the one hand you've got
negative charge filling that need is
amounts to a positive charge so you've
got the duality of charges and that's
the way things work in the CT right
there's utility deficit and then there's
utility
so that's what the the ETS is just that
part of your mind that that syntactic
module that tells you
what you should be doing I mean it makes
you feel very you know
fight uh flee
um you know go up and ask that girl for
a date you know this is the kind of
thing that's that it's that it's telling
you a pain I've got to jerk my hand away
from the flame okay all right and then
you've got you've got fulfillment you've
got emotions of fulfillment which then
tell where they reinforce this cycle of
charge and and uh you know of deficit
and fulfillment okay when you feel happy
it means that you've just performed that
that thing properly you've actually just
closed that Loop okay and it reinforces
you to do the same thing in the future
and that's our reality more or less
conditions itself
to fulfill its own nature
Chris can you give me an example of a
time when you felt fear for weeks so not
just momentary fear particularly with
regard to something existential so this
is a personal question I want to know
how is it that you overcame some dread
and then Bernardo similarly you
mentioned that you had problems with
anxiety in the past
probably still do but a specific problem
is likely in your mind
well I I can't say that I have felt
prolonged dread in the past bouts of
dread of course we all do but in terms
of prolonged dread I've been you know
most mercifully free of that kind of I
have felt you know things protracted
uncomfortable feelings like loneliness
you know I mean you know I you know feel
feel lonely you know I cope with those
things by basically turning my mind in
another Direction in a direction that I
know could be fulfilled if there's no
one around like that you know I could be
you know that could be my companion and
I'm going to have to remain lonely I
make sure that I use my time well by
immersing myself in something that makes
me feel better distracting myself from
that need which cannot yet be fulfilled
and kind of transferring that into the
future okay I will solve this problem
later but now I'm going to do what needs
doing
okay
Bernardo
I have experienced dread for over a
decade and pretty much continuously
um a lot of My Philosophy work has been
a sort of an Alchemy of uh
um translating
that undesired undesirable energy of
dread into something positive Nietzsche
talked about this being the job of
philosophers turning everything we are
everything we fear into love and Flame
as we put it I said that was the job of
philosophy and I think he he was right
um for me it started
um in my mid-30s when I was 34 I had
achieved everything that I set myself to
achieve when I was 12 and when I was 12
my father died and I made a list of
everything I wanted to achieve in my
life one day I woke up at 34 and I
realized that it everything sticked it's
all there and I thought I've arrived I'm
in control I have control of the world
because I had external control of the
world I had a good job I had sufficient
money I had the house I always wanted to
have I was married to my youth
sweetheart
um
and then in life has a funny way to
confront you with your own [ __ ] very
very quickly so it's it didn't take
weeks of that feeling I am in control
for me to find a nodule in my wife's
breast
which took doctors two weeks to rule out
as cancer
and in those two weeks I thought
[ __ ] I'm not in control at all
my wife can get sick and die I can get
sick and die everything that I find
important all those people can no I have
no control over my own body let alone
the world and that realization was was
terrible to me I internalized that into
health anxiety for myself health anxiety
for everybody that I cared about
and um it took well over 10 years for
that claustrophobic feeling
to to sort of dissipate and I I wish I
would have you know the seven steps to
getting rid of that
um uh two things happened to me prior to
it dissipating
one
I accepted that it would never go away
which is amazing now when you truly
accept in your heart of hearts that okay
this is not something I can fight this
is not a problem I can solve I have
tried everything for over 10 years every
recipe in the book everything
man didn't solve it so I might have to
live with it and I truly accepted that
in the core of my being that I will live
with anxiety
that was one precursor the other
precursor was reconnecting with my child
self
my child self from before my father died
and I suddenly instantly turned into an
adult
reconnecting with that way of being in
the world that is when you're not trying
to control the world when you are in
full communion with the world you're not
trying to control your destiny you're
not thinking about the future you don't
have lists about things that need to be
achieved
um you're just there for the world
enjoying the moment and you're taken by
the wind with the flow of life and
reconnecting with that which to me had
had to do with know my passion for
computers and I started designing my own
computers that what I always wanted to
do when I was a kid and I went to
University at 17 and I designed
computers for others but never designed
my own computer so I started doing that
and somewhere in the course of two years
that conjunction of
accepting fear
accepting that it would never go away
that it's not a problem to be solved
and reconnecting with my child self
somehow don't tell me I cannot tell you
how or when one day I woke up and I
looked back over the previous two years
and I realized
wow I haven't been anxious I still have
you know some crisis here and there but
uh
I tuned into what I like to call the the
movements of being personal in my mind
um sometimes I personalize it and I call
it the diamond
and I say you know my life now is about
doing the diamonds uh bidding
um my life's not about me anymore and
that's sort of that acceptance that my
life is not about me that I'm just here
riding a wave Nature's trying to do
something through me and my only choice
is do I resist that or do I not
and naturally and very spontaneously
making the choice to not resist it means
that you you surrender control
so if you ask me where do I want to be
in five years I would just laugh at your
face I have no idea and I have no need
to know
um I will be where I will be in five
years so long as I keep in tune with the
movements of the impersonal within me
and I'm completely relaxed with that and
that surrender of control
was a surrender of fear
because if you don't feel that you need
to be in control
fear does not have fertile ground to to
grow and and take hold because you're
not trying to be in control
um there is a kind of a an acceptance of
the impersonal an acceptance that you're
just a part of nature it's like that
Blossom of my apple tree telling itself
where do I want to be in five days and
it's ridiculous it's not about the
blossom it's not even about the tree
it's about the whole flow of Nature and
when you internalize that Insight at
least for me when I internalize that
Insight not because I tried not because
I had a plan to internalize it it just
happened I I realized it with hindsight
you know just by looking back I realized
this Dynamic played out it happened I
somehow let go
of the need to control of the need to
plan I surrendered into the movements of
the impersonal
and I'm fine I'm surprisingly fine I
still have horrible tinnitus in both
years I hear dentists drill in both my
ears very loud constantly 24 hours a day
thought about suicide twice three and a
half years ago
I mean peace with that even how did this
happen I have no idea how this happened
I have no recipes I couldn't tell you
follow these steps I can only tell you
what the precursors for me were and I
still experience fear and dread
occasionally but it's nowhere near that
ride I used to have now the bad news is
I feel a lot less energy to write
um I feel a lot less need to write it's
like the diamond used my dread
to Corral me into doing its bidding and
now that it
can't use it anymore I I'm much much
more in the now
um if you ask me what my intuition
points to my intuition is that I will
still play with computers old computers
and designing my own computers for
another year or two to exhaust that that
childhood need and to be really in
communion with my child self and after
that I sense I see it coming on the
horizon a whole new phase of writing
will come but much more mature writing
much more centered writing not writing
driven by
dread driven by the diamond but more
centered more
um more mature more adult writing which
will be a lot less conceptual because
it's more adult
that's what I sense so knock on wood
let's hope that that's how things will
play out but uh I don't need to know if
that's what will happen what will happen
is what will happen that's how I Live
Now
Chris do you have any thoughts on that
does anything occur to you or any
stories come to mind after you hear that
well it's uh of course I I there's value
in bernardo's advice and his his
anecdote I tend to have a much more
focused
uh view of the future and that's not to
say that I
plan everything in advance but I strive
to see the possibilities and then strive
to make out the one that best that is
optimal for my purposes and constantly
just you know I'm more of a driven
person I don't have
these these emotions that plague me on
you know all the time the way some
people do God bless them I mean it's
difficult to have to put up with that
but I'm more of a purpose-driven animal
okay and this is what this is the way I
approach reality and when I have when I
have some I I you know some people for
example
um I was in the bar business for years I
was a bouncer and there are some people
who just you know you throw them out of
a bar they don't forgive and forget
you know they're now become they fixate
on Revenge and they can't let go of it
and they can't I'm the kind of person
who can instantly let go of that kind of
thing I feel anger you know sometimes
and if the anger is to attest that bad
things can happen but if I if I can get
through that if I can stop from becoming
enraged then it's 10 minutes later I'm
just fine
unless unless it was such a serious
thing that I can't afford to be fine if
you know what I mean okay but I can let
go of things very easily and then divert
myself onto what I consider to be a more
productive track
this is something that you know if I
have the energy and as Bernardo was
talking about sometimes you just don't
feel the energy because it's like
there's a diamond sucking the energy out
of you for its own purposes and trying
to turn you in a certain direction or
what uh or whatnot and that is something
that I very much try to avoid if I
realize well there seems to be something
Beyond me that is using me in some way
I curtail it unless I discern that it's
good for me
so I'm constantly making these judgments
about purpose and about you know what I
should be doing you know and about my
impulses subjecting them to to cognition
and you know cognition is not progress
especially not a primary function it
comes out of out of will a lot of
Telesis which is what we've been talking
about here okay
um just like uh just like access
Consciousness for example as opposed to
phenomenal consciousness okay it's a
that all is is post-tellic to me right
so so although I do use cognition for
purposes of reflection you know all of
this takes place with me on a on an
emotional level beneath the surface
okay in other words I realize okay it's
not gonna this is going to lead to bad
feelings I'm not going to be satisfied
doing this immediately I change
directions and try to get myself on a
track that is going to be more
productive for me and not going to
subject me to you know any kind of bad
feelings or in the will or anything like
that
let me be personal for a couple minutes
maybe three minutes
I've spoken about this issue on the
podcast before you can see either the
Carl friston part 2 podcast or the Diana
posoka podcast for more information you
can also skip forward five minutes I
didn't know what it meant to take that
seriously until I felt it it's different
to feel something than it is to analyze
it
anyway so I felt it terrified terrified
out of my mind
and I remember something calling me to
the center something calling me saying
Kurt you have you've been keeping your
mind far too open there is such a thing
as when people say
keep your mind open but not so open that
your head falls out I remember
saying hey yeah that's just to justify
your own close-mindedness something was
saying there's truth to that come back
to the center come back not to say that
it's not real like you have to decide
there is a reality to it but you have to
decide this
and so from like like I feel like my for
the past few months almost all of my
thoughts like it's abating my anxiety is
abating but I feel like I'm constantly
preventing myself from a nervous
breakdown and what's helped is is a
middle ground between you both which is
to retain a sense of control so
something called ACT therapy acceptance
and commitment therapy so you accept
that's where Bernardo you come in where
it's like okay you accept that you know
these thoughts are simply thoughts and
they may occur just like the thoughts
occur to everyone don't think you're
ever going to get rid of them and maybe
they will become zero but don't think
that and then also to accept the
thoughts but not to merge with them not
fuse with them except simply means
acknowledge softly gently I see you
thought interesting that you're there I
don't need to take you seriously and
then just go to where your values are
and you commit to where your values are
which is where the control comes in so
you have to have some value so my values
are my wife and and love and and this
this world and seeing behind my eyes and
actually feeling like I'm behind my eyes
which was not there from the two months
or so like it's depersonalized
anyway
I've come to the decision now that what
matters is
is not a toll is like I used to love toe
like doing everything speaking to to and
learning great theories and I still love
that I still do that actually gives me
some same some sanity if it's not
Consciousness related if it's math and
physics because it's dispassionate but
what's primary is my relationship with
my wife and love and so if I have to
sacrifice a toe day of studying to go
spend time with my wife I do almost
invariably that was never there before
work comes first before now it's like no
no Kurt almost everything May fade in
some manner all of what I'm putting out
on YouTube may fit people may take it
out of context people may shape it but
just like the Nirvana logo kids wear it
it used to be from Nirvana the band kids
have no idea who Nirvana is but they
wear the shirt the term Nirvana used to
mean something Buddhist but Nirvana took
that and so constantly something will
get taken away from you and change
that's out of your hand love is primary
just follow that
so that's what I guide Myself by now
and that's given me some sanity the way
I imagine it is almost like a pendulum
instead of now swinging it to the other
side which was me before trying to avoid
no I don't want to think don't want to
think that that makes it come back it's
a gentle
nudge to the center I try not to run
from it but it's not the same as facing
it which is what I thought I had to do
it's more the same as just interesting
huh
okay let me move toward what I what I
value I want to put warning signs on all
my interviews now because of that
because like some people just
advice should be advice should be
taken slowly
anyway
they're saying that this is some
Awakening and there's this quote from
H.P Lovecraft which I agree with which
is hey the the one of the greatest
mercies of the world is our inability to
correlate its contents the whole
realities contents and as soon as you do
you may go mad from the Revelation or or
beg for the ignorance of the past and
flee into the darkness from the light
and Jacobi last quote Jacoby had a quote
don't know which Jacoby there's like 12
of them
that humans have one choice but a single
choice either God or nothingness by
choosing nothingness man makes himself
into a God because it means everything
around you is an apparition now don't
follow that logic but regardless I like
the the Poetics behind it he said so
there's only one choice
God exists outside of me as a living
being in and of himself or I am God
there is no third I think that's true
that's that all right so now you have
like great insight into Kurt the past
few months
the reason I tell you all this is
because well
hey Eddie delicate advice if you've gone
through something similar I'm extremely
appreciative of
well I don't think that it's quite
accurate to say there are only these two
Alternatives either I have to be God or
God has to exist entirely outside of me
okay there is a there's a middle ground
there and as a matter of fact I would
affirm that middle ground and say that
if you if you make this false dichotomy
out of it either I have to be God you
know it's totally solipsistic Universe
right that that is a mistake basically
you're dissociating yourself from your
true highest level of identity and you
can't afford to do that you have to try
to take in the little structure and
understand it's very very difficult you
know I mean Lovecraft may have thought
that this is you know something that
drives you into the arms of thulu you
know or or whatever you know
nevertheless it is absolutely necessary
for you to maintain your psychological
equilibrium okay it's homeostatic okay
you mentioned God a lot during this this
uh this disquisition here and God is a
uh is a fixture now in your awareness
and that's a very very good thing okay
when you talk about God says you know
your in Philippians it says you know
throw your your cares on to God okay you
can't hand your cares off to God unless
you're close to God unless you're
actually within standing disc you can
hand them off and that's the whole point
of that basically you you know to hand
things off to God he's the same as
handing them off to your own highest
level of identity
okay it's not outside you're a part of
it you're a lower stratum but that
identity actually spans you and spans
all of reality your feature of reality
you're an aspect of the part of reality
so you have to keep this in mind it's a
myriology it's the relationship of a
part to its whole and if you keep that
in mind and that is what the ctmu is
about by the way it's a myriology if you
keep that in mind then you will remain
in balance with the rest of reality
that would be my helpful advice
Bernardo man
who am I to render
advice
um I'm younger than Chris
if I can share something with you is
that it this is life it's it's the
process of life life buffets us and
brings us to the edge and it should if
you if it's not bringing you to the edge
you're not living fully
the art is to navigate The Edge without
falling down the precipice but
navigating The Edge because that's the
path of maturation that's the path of
change otherwise you will always remain
with your then the same narratives the
same Illusions such as the illusion of
identity the illusion of control these
things don't go away
um if you if you're not tested by life
so hey who rate what's happening to you
it it may feel
extremely uncomfortable but that's the
point that's the point if you're always
in your comfort zone you're not going
anywhere and one day you will wake up in
your deathbed and think what was this
all about what was this for I wasted the
whole thing now that's not going to be
your destiny my friend you're not going
to that dark place
um
there was something else I wanted to
share with you but uh it just escaped my
mind you just used a phrase if you don't
mind I rejecting you basically said the
illusion of identity
now I understand that you have that in
analytic
idealism you've got the idea that this
is something like like
some kind of identity disorder you know
this dissociative identity disorder in
which everybody is an alter
of this one primary Primal identity
right is that what you're referring to
that it is it is illusory to think of
you is that what the illusion of
identity is if you force me down the
conceptual path I would have to say yes
but I I was not trying to speak
conceptually I'm I'm not trying to speak
Theory to to Kurt uh theory is here
and Kurt oh I remember now
what you're suffering from is something
that the vast majority of people have
the opposite problem you internalize
a narrative you internalize a world view
you are able of you're capable of
internalizing it it comes from your head
purely conceptual it sinks into the body
and you can live from the perspective of
that world view and and that's what you
experience as testing your balance
testing your centeredness or or
threatening to make you lose yourself
because you can embody what for most
people is purely a conceptual narrative
most people have the opposite problem
they cannot embody a narrative they're
incapable of making that translation and
what that means is that even if they
understand certain things and they make
progress cognitively in understanding it
doesn't change their lives it doesn't
touch their emotions they continue to to
live according to Old patterns to Old
references because that's there is a
level in which they don't actually
believe the conceptual narratives you
have your gates open
that is a tremendous Advantage compared
to most people but also a liability
because you have to watch that gate
carefully you can you can put yourself
in a place from which it's very hard to
emerge again but
everything you said
to me I'll just say you know hooray
cheers to life you're living
congratulations man
I'm going to comment on the illusory
aspect
because here's one aspect that gave me
groundedness was when I was speaking to
this professor of religion named Diana
pasoka she was saying Kurt don't worry
that half of the world thinks that I am
God and so on because you don't know
what they mean by that I don't have the
like I have an idea of what they mean it
could be misinterpreting what they mean
they could be wrong at the same time
millions and billions of people have
been wrong all of these practices
meditation and psychedelics they're
meant to be done with the community and
all these insights she said she would
imagine if you went to some leader and
you told them this Insight they'd be
like oh no like that's what that's
completely wrong like you're not
you are not God like you are an aspect
of God or whatever it may be
and then she also said the Plato's Cave
Journeys what's what's happening or The
Dark Knight of the Soul she used that
phrase she said
the actual full story of that or you
think this is reality of the wall you
come out you feel like that's an
illusion then the end of the story is to
somehow realize that what you
thought was real in the beginning is
indeed real it's just real in another
manner like somehow more real and then I
remember something Bernardo that you
said look at this this we think of a
solid we feel it there's solidity to it
yet we look at it through a microscope
and we say yeah the atoms are far apart
this is the solidity is an illusion uh
that's if you take materialism as
primary what if you take your conscious
experience no no this is solid this
actually is solid there's something real
about that there's something real about
this table there's something real about
me inhabiting this world I can go
through this process where I feel like
oh that's all an illusion but then
there's this quote about T.S Eliot that
the point of the journey is to come back
where you started and know the place for
the first time I feel like that I'm
slowly starting where I feel the reality
of this more I feel it but then there's
a nagging part of me that's like yeah
you're tricking yourself great you're
tricking yourself
we let our theories hijack the reality
of our experiences and that's a tragedy
experiences are not nothing they're the
only thing that is really real that's
not just abstraction so it doesn't
matter that you oh there are atoms here
and then the distance between the
electron orbitals and the nucleus is
enormous relative to the to the diameter
of the particles themselves yeah it's
all true but you experience this you
hold this it has weight it has texture
it
it feels moist and it satiates my thirst
this is all real stuff
now
a conceptual understanding a conceptual
narrative behind that maybe true or not
but it doesn't take away from the
experience whatever this is it is an
experience and it is real as such
the problem is that we we are in a
society which implicitly tells us
experiences in themselves are nothing
it's the thing that lies behind the
experience that counts that's
absolutely nonsensical all we have is
experience
The Narrative behind it can help us
develop a certain understanding but not
by robbing us of the immediacy of
experience which ultimately is is all we
have we can add understanding to that
but that understanding is a layer on top
of the immediacy of experience and look
the ego
exists it's a tool without it I wouldn't
note which mouth to bring the fork so
there is something there that we call
the ego
now is it your subjectivity in and of
itself or not that's a valid question I
would answer that it the ego is not your
subjectivity it it's it's a certain
configuration of experiences or a
narrative within your subjectivity and
yes ideallyism ultimately it's a form of
cosmic solipsism and you can dip your
toes in those Waters and you recoil from
it I call it the vertigo of Eternity
um it's a place that um
is very hard to visit very hard to
confront
um which may be a clue to why we are
here you know in this form
um but maturing has always to do with
poking you out of your comfort zone and
and and buffetting you a little uh and
and you just have to hold the boat
together so it can continue to navigate
and not sink but I I don't think there
is anything intrinsically bad about
the fact that the waters are trying and
it's it's trying and stuff uh and that's
how we progress I mean I I
I'm not a prophet I'm not going to
predict your future and you come from a
different place than me your life has a
different context what holds to me may
not hold to you please hold to you but
now I'm going to do exactly what I said
I wouldn't do which is make a prediction
so forgive me for that okay but
moment
there will come a moment
when you realize that your problems will
dissipate not because you answered your
questions but because you no longer feel
the need to ask them
yeah I'll leave it at that
okay so Chris whatever thoughts come to
you and then we can move on to another
couple questions I'm sorry to go on this
aside you were just communicating with
your own highest level of identity so
okay that's that's basically God and the
reason that you are able to communicate
with God is that you are an aspect of
God
right God is reality he's the Ultimate
Reality almost has to be that way
otherwise it makes no sense to call
something God okay you are a part of God
and you are a stratum of God's identity
it's as simple as that and you give rise
to things and your experiences
they are identities your experiences
experience is not something that can't
it is it's one unary you know coherent
thing and yet it can be teased apart
into this idea of form of substance okay
it's basically an experience as an
interface it's an interface between you
and reality it's you accepting input
from the outside world or internal input
from yourself okay and transducing it
and then turning that into a thought or
into Behavior okay this is this is what
it is this is what it's doing for you so
your experience is even your your purely
mental experiences are of utmost value
to you they are identities there are
that are a part of your identity and you
are a part of a greater identity
okay so you've got this Continuum of
identities all right and it's it's a
nested it's it's kind of a you know a
it's a it's a Russian doll so it's uh
it's you know
uh matrushka you know matrushka dolls I
forget anyway basically it's one thing
nested within another you've got a
highest level of identity your identity
is nested in it and your experience is
invested in you they're all identities
okay putting all of those things
together is what it seems to me that
you're doing a very very valuable thing
so I would say keep up the good work
well hey man it's like any compliment
from you is a it's an honor so let's
just end this with
what you all value what do you value
most
Chris
what do I value most
uh god
um what's the identity of reality
um and of course
supporting and and aiding the
Fulfillment of reality I believe the
reality actually has a goal a
teleological purpose that it that it is
that it is determined by its structure
basically it's built into what it is and
that it is my job to fulfill help
reality fulfill that that that it's
goals it's teleological impetus which
derives from its structure because I'm a
part of it and it's my own highest level
of identity and it's my job to help it
just as as it helps me okay I'm carried
within it I exist within it so I'm going
to return the favor and I'm going to try
to reinforce it as much as I can that's
what's valuable to me and then of course
we have all of the things that are
valuable to everybody you know the idea
of of love you know I mean I have a wife
so I have home I have you know pets I
have dogs that that love me you know the
taste of a good meal you know or a good
drink right having fun with your friends
right going out and enjoying nature all
of those things are valuable to me but
the one the one basic imperative that I
feel is to integrate with reality
perfectly cope reality reinforce itself
right because that's all there is there
is nothing outside of that you try to
extricate yourself from reality like the
Buddhists are trying to do and you end
up in Nirvana and you're nothing your
identity has at that point fused without
of the entire universe and you no longer
have an individual identity at all your
identity is a self-distributed thing
that covers everything and you have lost
your identity as you know okay you're
here and you feel your individual
identity and that's very very important
okay if your job your job the the job of
your identity is not only to enjoy life
as you were put here to do but also to
help life and to help reality reinforce
itself
right that's what I consider value
Bernardo
uh the answer I will give you is not the
answer I would like to give you I would
like to tell you I value love the most
relationships the most human decency and
justice
um
Nietzsche struggled with this question
and he answered power
is what
because he considered the most important
the wheel to power and contrast to
Freud's will to pleasure
um
but the truth is and you know it part of
maturing is accepting your own truths
and on the truth is about yourself even
when you don't like it
the truth is
that for me the most important thing is
truth
and that I would probably
surrender everything else
to stare the truth in the face whatever
the price
whatever it cost that for me is is is
the highest calling it's how I'm put
together it's not how I
wish I was put together
um
to to prioritize truth above all else is
not trivial yeah again Nietzsche he was
very explicit about that he said why do
we want to know the truth
what's the point he thought it was
ridiculous it was a knee-jerk reflex
that if we thought it through we would
abandon it's not about what is true
um and I I've meditated on that for
years I I went to the extreme of
visiting the places where nature had
those thoughts which thank goodness are
recorded we know where he was and I I
probably stood within a meter of where
he stood
um
but at the end of all that struggle
it's it's the truth that shines through
and the truth is my highest commitment
is the truth that's that's how I am I I
yeah I hate it in a sense but that's how
I am
thank you all so much for coming out
this was
thank you thank you all this was
well enlightening in many ways okay I
would just once again repeat after that
after that uh the conspiring comment by
Bernardo the truth and reality are
basically two ways of looking at the
same thing when you say that's real or
something is real you are saying that it
is true
okay and when you say that something is
true you're saying that it's real so in
dedicating yourself to truth you also
dedicate yourself to reality and both of
our comments both what what both of us
said combined in this one
interest
that's one real truth
the same thing
thank you all
I hope you had fun
more than that
and thank you for being so open for
being so
truthful and and so all there
with the rest of us it's been very much
my my pleasure thank you so much I think
both thanks both of you yes YouTube
take care all right man bye bye
the podcast is now finished if you'd
like to support conversations like this
then do consider going to patreon.com
c-u-r-t-j-a-i-m-u-n-g-a-l that is Kurt J
Mongol it's support from the patrons and
from the sponsors that allow me to do
this full-time every dollar helps
tremendously thank you
and a special thank you to Jeannie
Langan whose diligence made this all
possible thank you Genie